[Musique]
alors vous voyez présentement des images
qui vous proviennent du canada qui ont
été filmés certainement il ya au moins -
un an à ce que toutes les saisons là
comme ça qu apparaissent alors bienvenue
à tomtom canada en direct de montréal
11h15 seller à montréal il ya 6 heures
différentes et demi au canada c'est ce
fuseau horaire et demi c'est incroyable
et pour vous accueillir aujourd'hui bien
sûr votre animateur préféré stéphane
parent il y en a qu un animateur lors
c'est bien sûr pour lui préférer et
matthew geise bonjour mathieu bonjour
stephen alors merci beaucoup de vous
joindre à nous on a eu le plaisir de
vous présenter lorsque vous avez
commencé à travailler avec nous c'est
trop mon dieu ça fait quand même un bon
boutin fait pas loin deux mois c'est pas
plus oui oui exactement
ouais mais même eux mêmes plus oui vous
avez quand même beaucoup de gens de
métier vous avez travaillé pour
dites-vous peut pas tout dire parce que
vous avez un bon pas bon cru que le
muter malgré votre jeune âge le vitrail
où exactement
j'ai travaillé pour la bbc world service
je travaille pour l' agence
france-presse
entre autres après j'ai travaillé pour
d'autres médias comme al jazeera ou
performe iliaque et plus du sport et
dans le domaine des ugc qui écoute et on
est bien content nous avons avec nous
d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui on n'est
que deux à faire cette émission et il
nous manque un vieux lion de la
diffusion
on ne m'aura pas cet homme il s'agit
quand même d'un homme en terrassonnais
voilà alors coûté rien le chargea
l'émission malgré l'absence d'un joueur
très important futile
je vous présente tous la vidéo 5 images
vous devinez tous ensemble quel est le
sujet de notre émission aujourd'hui et
matthew est le premier qui se trouve sur
la sellette qui va crier haut et fort
lorsqu'ils pensent avoir deviné le sujet
de notre émission pendant qu'on diffuse
cette image du héros de le vieux lion de
la diffusion s'approche du studio allait
vraiment des marques d'eau quel est le
sujet démission aujourd'hui l'image du
numéro 4 chez que vous savez lire anti
langue
vous n'êtes pas là ici alors on parle de
quoi aujourd'hui
lens en haïti notamment ouais surtout et
on parle du peut-être moi c'est ça moi
j'ai fait quelques pas puis là dessus
cette semaine au sujet de et la semaine
dernière si ça les motive à au sujet de
disette des recommandations
d'interdiction de voyage du gouvernement
canadien
donc c'est vous j'ai remarqué ça c'est
pour çà veut inspirer dans le sujet
cette semaine j'étais vraiment et
s'intéresse beaucoup à ça au jour tout
le monde sait pas le seul d'ailleurs il
ya ali se chargea le tandem qui a aussi
signé quelques papiers là dessus on va
retrouver sa plus tard à l'émission vous
montrer à quoi ressemble cette
production des dernières des dernières
semaines soit cinq semaines alors semble
qu'à des troupes de présentement en
haïti hausse a commencé avec des
histoires de pénurie de ci de ça surtout
de pétrole et ça dégénère
certains parlent peut-être d'une guerre
civile il ya des craintes exprimées
notamment par la diaspora haïtienne qui
se trouvent essentiellement à montréal
lorsqu'on parle la diaspora au canada se
trouve essentiellement à manger les
haïtiens ou en grande majorité bien
contente d'avoir l'émission est vraiment
parce que vous en savez beaucoup sur
cette histoire dont sur ces histoires
lui la main d'haïti des dictateurs de la
contestation actuellement contre le
président qui a été élu je pense ya pas
loin de deux ans nouveau président je
voulais montrer des images de ce nouveau
président hier c'est à nous vient de
voir se refermer un cas qui est qui
ressemble peu à radio canada
international m on parle là sourit
d'éléphants bien sûr on le fait branler
le pont d'un côté on va regarder donc
notre vidéo numéro deux produits hier
par voici un cas dans les rues de port
au prince
on célébrait la la fondation d'haïti
1848 je pense je pense donc puisque
normalement c'est un événement où tout
le monde participe grande foule
populaire et là il était entouré par des
centaines de policiers le président
parce qu'il ya des manifestants qui
commençaient à cerner que l'endroit où
il était venu se recueillir sur la tombe
du fondateur d'haïti alors ça c'est donc
des images les plus fraîches
plusieurs stations n'ont pas encore
diffusé ce que je vous présentais en ce
moment d'accord je parle pas
d'exclusivité ne vient pas de nous mais
c'est quand même un bon geste de la part
de vie aux idées présentes sur le
terrain ce qui m'amène à vous parler des
diasporas ici à montréal
ce que vous avez des données que vous
aimeriez partager année nous serons
d'accord bon c'est vous qui avez donné
on va commencer donc par nos jeux de la
grosse bol y en a 3 l'émission qui nous
permet donc de cerner davantage le sujet
êtes prêt matthew très bien à je dois
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui ça va être
difficile
on part avec 100% l'examen suite ça
dégringole d'accord premier jeu vous
pourriez perdre 20% à l'examen on est
prêt oui bruno bulletin d'hier on peut
mieux faire
c'était là les mois je t'aime toujours
comme ça pourrait beaucoup mieux valait
alors premier tour on regarde la
question c'est au sujet ne disent pas on
pense que les nouvellement arrivés mais
non de 1760 à 1834 quel pourcentage des
personnes esclavage et à montréal ne
venait de saint domingue qui était
l'ancien nom donné à aujourd'hui à haïti
est-ce que c'était à 3% des esclaves à
montréal était d'origine de saint
domingue
b 13% des esclaves c'est 23 % des ex
lave ou encore j'adore le des qui
complique encore les résultats d'examens
33% des esclaves
dites moi c'est pas une page très très
heureuse de l'histoire canadienne
non pas du tout vous l'aurez 10 23% des
moindres est ce donc j'ai un 13 pour ça
et j'ai 1 23%
je vais regarder moi quelle est la bonne
réponse nous on va de l'affiché dans le
bas je pense que regarder ça ressemble à
ça ça s'en vient ça s'en vient le
suspense demain pour le mode d'hambourg
voilà cette fois soit pour ça à bien ce
que j'ai trouvé très intéressant comme
ça parce que je me dis pourquoi % ça
fait du monde c'était seulement cinq ex
clave esclaves 5s classe seulement donc
the ce n'était pas un grand phénomène ne
m'ont rien la présence de ce clanwar
mais ça existe et ça a commencé sous le
régime britannique ça s'est poursuivi
sous le régime français français aux
états unis est originaire de françois
plutôt mauvaise à au plus tôt lundi
ce serait je le régime plusieurs films
français que vous êtes là pour ça de
connivence
c'est très bien c'est fantastique dont
vous avez tous les deux perdu 20 boules
dans sur les seins
faites attention à lui parce que
l'indicé view lingway va faire qu'une
bouchée tout le monde ici on va se
tourner vers monsieur frantz voltaire
qui un jour france commence à lui vous
bonjour ça va très bien heureux de vous
retrouver à on va dire c'est le
directeur du centre international de
documentation et d'information haïtienne
et guinéenne monsieur voltaire fait
combien d'années que vous habitez à
montréal au canada depuis 1973 pour la
première fois je suis reparti en 75 du
revenu en 80 donc vous faites partie
peut-être de cette deuxième vague
d'immigration haïtienne des temps
modernes y en a une en 2060 d'une autre
dans les années 70 c'est ce que vous
diriez que ça correspond un peu à votre
à votre expérience personnelle
on pourrait dire il est de la deuxième
génération eu d'une certaine façon oui
parce que il y en a qui sont bien
d'avoir des morts qui ont eu 99 ans donc
je je fais juste le milieu là c'est bien
parlez moi de la diaspora à montréal
ensuite on verra comment elle réagit à
ce qui se passe parce que beaucoup de
familles encore il ya des amis qui sont
un outil alors décrivez moi cette
diaspora l'importance pour montréal ou t
on à une diaspora d'aujourd'hui à
montréal toutes origines confondues et
c'est pourquoi je prendrais plutôt des
communautés haïtiennes que de la
communauté de revenus des problèmes de
classes des problèmes de temps de
présence à montréal
et donc on a une passe port à d'environ
150000 personnes toutes origines
confondues et elle est présente dans
tous les milieux
puisque dépendant de l'époque de
l'animation la première rame ou et monte
pour les premiers arrivés ici dans les
années 1920 parce qu'on a retrouvé que
la première association haïtienne date
de 1930
c'est l'association amitié haïti québec
haïti canada et après il y a eu vent des
vagues successives d'exilés et plus tard
des vagues d'immigrants économiques ont
dit vivement professionnels plus
récemment et la dernière drague c'est
celle qui est venue peut pas le chemin
oxfam
ce sont les derniers qui sont venus et
des états unis
évidemment on vient d'ailleurs si
souvent mais on repart très souvent on
repart revisiter les amis la famille
vous allez vous rendant moins de quatre
heures vous prenez un vol montréal
haïti un vol direct non mais non papa il
narguera un colloque à cuba à bord
écoutez moi je confonds c'est tellement
proches voilà on travaille aussi tu vas
y si la république dominicaine cuba et
la jamaïque donc on travaille comme
sentent aussi sur les amplis le donc là
je m'en vais pour un colloque cas de
l'unesco à la havane alors vous vous
préoccuper de cette question vous n'êtes
pas le seul que pense la communauté où
les communautés présentement de ce qui
se passe c'est pas la première fois que
des troubles un outil qu'est ce qui
ressort cette fois dans l'est dans les
pensées dans les coeurs des citoyens qui
qui nous côtoient ici à montréal ou au
canada
alors on est en face d'une crise qui
doit débuter l'année dernière il faut
bien comprendre que cette crise début
est là c'est une crise systémique crise
économique d'abord parce que il y a eu
des détournements massifs
on parle du projet de petro caribe est
en fait c'est intéressant beaucoup de
gens qui ont levé la question du petro
caribe c'est-à-dire jeunes et certains
d'entre eux étaient aux journées à
montréal où avait vécu à montréal assez
longtemps j'étais retourné en haïti ce
sont les premiers qui ont commencé à
contester ces détournements massifs on
parle de plus de 3 milliards de dollars
qui ont été détournés et cela ce sont
des prêts c'est à dire qu'haïti devra
les rembourser
on a parlé aussi de la crise qui n'est
du tremblement de terre
et là on a un problème majeur c'est à
dire c'est ces fonds promis pour la
reconstruction d'haïti qui en fait ne
sont jamais allés vraiment un haïti et
on parle de milliards de dollars ça a
été le cas je n'ai pas géré par la
fondation qui nous tombent donc il ya un
certain nombre de mécontentement base
aussi sur le fait que si ce président a
été élu il a été élu avec moins de 500
mille voix et en plus il a été suivant
beaucoup d'observateurs internationaux
il a été aussi imposer un outil et là on
a un problème c'est toi la présidente
qui s'il est reconnu par l'international
n'avait pas de légitimité
ce président a fait des promesses
inconsidérées avec sa caravane qui a été
un gouffre dans l'utilisation de fonds
publics
et je crois que pour la première fois il
y a une conscience citoyenne de que les
détournements de fonds la corruption e
affecte directement le bien-être des
gens puisque que ça remet en question le
fonctionnement du système scolaire du
système de santé et donc il y à une
contestation qui est né et ce président
n'a jamais je veux dire voler aux
grandes rues des comptes s'ils ont un
compte à tout cela le fait que le
président cette défaite son premier
ministre un premier ministre qui était
né de la première crise donc d'un
compromis il y a quelques mois et que on
se retrouve sans gouvernement
je dirais sans gouvernement légal il y à
un gouvernement de fait dans l'amas de
gouvernement légal ou au promu par le
parlement on a aussi un effondrement du
parlement les gens accusaient les
députés sénateurs d'appropriation un
dieu de fonds donc on est en face d'une
crise généralisée c'est tout le pays qui
s'est mobilisée et cette crise est
peut-être la plus grave depuis la chute
de temples du bagne vous franz walter
vous aller très très loin en disant que
c'est la plus grave ou serait la plus
grave depuis la chute de
de bébé doc de jean claude duvalier
l'impression qu'on en a de l'extérieur
aussi c'est que c'est un ras-le-bol
généralisé qui s'installe mais avec
toujours une classe qui s'en met plein
les poches et qui trouvera sans doute
les moyens de continuer à leur faire ça
on le sait pas parce que vraiment moi
c'est la première fois que j'observe que
il s'agit pas simplement d'une
contestation est généralement opera la
capitale ou dans une comme dans une
deuxième ville comme le cas pour comme
les gonaïves des gonaïves juin à sion
est générale dans tout le pays on voit
les revendications c'est-à-dire que les
fonds soient jugés on fasse une
refondation de l'état haïtien et en même
temps les nations unies qui depuis dix
ans il ya une protestation aussi du rôle
des nations unies de la présence
internationale parce qu'on se dit c'est
cette présence internationale qui a
imposé en partie ses dirigeants et donc
ils n'ont plus de marge de crédit
donc on est en face de ce qui menace
peut-être un éclatement
parce que on a vu que ce président est
complètement isolé même des milieux
d'affaires qui étaient proches se sont
désolidarisés du président je pense à
des hommes d'affaires qui ont qui ont
été très lié au régime comme un des
hommes d'affaires les plus importants
d'eyetv finale boulos certains autres le
forum économique donc il y à un
ras-le-bol les brisants les catholiques
les protestants les universités les
écrivains c'est à dire ce président
contesté le pape il est en croit le
verrou du système bon sur ce on ne se la
puis la reconnaissance par le cor groupe
qui est une sorte de syndicat
d'ambassadeur de la france du canada des
états unis du brésil reconnaît encore le
président messieurs président contesté
pas tout il ne gouvernera bien ils
peuvent comme disent les gens appellent
ils arrivent ils font palais donc c'est
la première fois que moi j'observe une
crise de cette dimension
est ce que la population à d'autres
recours que les manifestations qu'elles
font actuellement ce qu'il ya de bien
d'autres recours possible pour changer
la situation
je vois très difficilement parce que les
institutions n'ont pas été à la hauteur
et elles mêmes elles sont contestées
aujourd'hui les gens veulent une refonte
possiblement du pacte qui a eu de 87 qui
était la constitution de 87
les gens veulent un changement de régime
parce que ils veulent mettre fin à a
succédé aux victimes où la corruption
prédomine et où les gens s'en mettent
plein les poches au détriment de la
grande majorité de la population est ce
que c'est possible rallystique mans
d'arriver à cela de changer la
constitution de changer ce système mois
de noeux malheureusement je ne lis pas
dans le marc de café
je n'ai pas de solution à proposer
d'autres comme observateurs je me rends
compte qu'on est en face d'une situation
quasi insurrectionnelle
certes la police peut continuer à
maintenir l'ordre mais on a eu sur
depuis un an
plus d'une centaine de morts 135 plus
précisément le on a des blessés et on a
aujourd'hui un système ou bien
fonctionné les écoles sont fermées des
universités sont fermées les hôpitaux ne
fonctionnent pas si vous allez les
supermarchés comment ça fonctionne
affirme et il va y avoir une crise
majeure
peut-être ça peut durer encore deux
semaines mais je ne vois pas comment ça
pourrait durer encore plus que de droit
de croire au grand maximum
mais celle là piste à swing c'est
toujours la piste de l'argent et ça a
été ça depuis depuis jeu depuis
duvalier père où va l'argent dans les
poches de qui vient le pouvoir on peut
acheter des gens qui vont faire des
contre manif qui vont par exemple
assassiner des journalistes on en a vu
quelques autres de tout récemment avait
et vous dit deux semaines mais tant et
aussi longtemps qu'on a le la poigne sur
ce ces milliards qui sont arrivés on
peut arriver croyez quelque part à tenir
un peuple bon manifester c'est bien beau
mais soit et mais il ya un point de
bascule vers lequel on s'en va que vous
voyez venir d'ici 15 jours
écoutez moi je dis petit je ne vois pas
comment ça va tenir
joe bradley nouvelle du côté du voisin
la république dominicaine qui avaient
des armes et fermer la frontière où ils
font des plans au cas où il y aurait une
masse de migrants a traversé la
frontière
on est dans une crise ou dans ce pays
s'il n'y a pas un changement qui donne
aux gens la possibilité que les choses
peuvent commencer à s'améliorer
je crois qu'on s'en va vers une crise
majeure qu'on aura des boat people qu'on
aura des tentatives de migrants mais
aussi et on peut passer à des situations
d'affrontements armés
d'abord le pouvoir a toléré pendant très
longtemps des bandes armées il suffit
qu'elle bascule donc moins notre
inquiétude c'est que plus ça dure cette
crise le président qui a levé ou de
cette crise
tan a trouvé une solution
institutionnelle à négocier sa sortie
plus centralisation ou regarder ne faut
pas non plus ce qui se passait ailleurs
l'eau d'après tarab cela dit on a hélas
la police ces quinze mille personnes
c'est très difficilement qu'elle
pourrait
comme le pouvoir donc si on a vite
dépassé et l'armée y a plus d'armée on
n'active pas dire il ya une constitution
d'une rixe jusque là c'est pas on n'a
pas d'âme
c'est un idiot pour mon ticket monsieur
voltaire il ya évidemment là
l'expression complicité des pays riches
j'ai vu quelques pancartes de
manifestants qui disent le canada les
etats-unis sortent et d'haïti on veut
plus on veut plus vous voir quelle
pourrait être la contribution de
certains politiciens de certaines
personnes au canada dans pressé de de
trouver une solution pour de faire
diminuer la tension est ce qu'on a
encore un rôle même s'il détecte 10
temple bon moi je crois que il faut ce
sont les états unis de trompes qui donne
le ton bon maintenant des autres pays
parce que ce n'est pas une zone
peut-être stratégie pour eux la france
ou le canada a son rôle secondaire comme
le brésil
mais les états unis peuvent aujourd'hui
compter sur l'appui du brésil est
certainement bon le canada reste encore
même si le président s'il le canada
prenait des positions ce serait une
attitude plutôt morale ou d'essayer de
convaincre les américains qu'il faut
trouver une solution institutionnelle à
cette crise si l'on ne veut pas être
débordé d'être dans une dans une
perspective de confrontation armée qui
d'une façon ou d'une autre pourrait se
matérialiser
si la crise continue et parce que vous
avez une population qui n'a plus rien à
perdre
vous avez écouté on vous avez une vie de
vue une manifestation dimanche à l'appel
des artistes c'est une manifestation
très pacifique
mais c'est 1,1 million de personnes
cette année entière de la vie a défilé
dans la ville
donc il faut quand même et trouver une
solution politique
et etde peut-être ce président à 100 à
l'est du pays conquis le soin et qu'il
se retire de la présidence monsieur
voltaire merci beaucoup nous avoir
communiqué ses plus récentes
informations puis votre analyse qui nous
mène au port qui nous fait voir les
choses qui pourraient se produire d'ici
quelques semaines au plus tard
c'est important je pense à ce moment ci
de commencer à parler avant qui est
vraiment une une crise plus que plus que
ce que vous nous avait raconté tout à
fait effroyable en perspective
merci beaucoup monsieur voltaire d'être
venu aujourd'hui l'émission merci
beaucoup monsieur voltaire merci au pays
france 1
balla gaye à l'arrière frantz voltaire
directeur du centre national de
documentation et d'information haïtienne
et caribéennes je m'attendais pas des
who do si mauvaise nouvelle j'avais lu
quelques articles toujours bon on voit
des vidéos on sait que ça c'était très
mauvais mois c'est très très très très
trouble on a vu des images qui nous
rappellent d'autres images mais celle ci
le décrivent un autre scénario
potentiellement alors écouter à
l'émission aujourd'hui j'aimerais quand
même reprendre les cordes on va faire le
sourire au moins ce vendredi vous savez
c'est toujours une occasion ici un petit
familles de se réunir de dire bonjour
parce qu'on est toujours très occupé
vous savez comme qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans les prochaines minutes
oui moi je serais zéro lag on y va c'est
parti deuxième grosse boule enfin
deuxième tour de la grosse boule comme
et boules à perdre 30 30
il a l'habitude le vieux côté c'est un
jeu latin de pommes mais charles ix on
vous a été de la réponse à ça peut-être
que vous avez souvenir de ça voyons voir
mathieu vous avez encore faire
intervenir si vos connaissances
générales votre intuition de
journalistes elle est très développé
dans lustin vraiment vous êtes vous
partez pas avec un handicap parce que
l'autre
là toute l'histoire voici deuxième
question canada at-elle inauguré il ya
deux fois le mais je pense que c'est
parce que vous appuyez sur le le le
premier vol direct entre montréal et au
prince
est-ce que c'était le 18 juillet 1998
est-ce que c'était bon le 23 septembre
est ce que c'était c'est le 29 octobre
1978 la c70 soixante dix huit pour
monsieur le moindre jeu monsieur
l'historienne à gérer sur de 1987 1987
alors je peux vous dire qu'elle a un des
deux qui qui conserve ses boules je sais
pas on va regarder un centre qui
concerne les boules et vous crier dès
que vous pensez que vous êtes vraiment
conscience et boul c'est bien c'est très
bien alors voila moi je n'ai pas dit 98
cherche à ce camp même sur un divan
ouais
écoutez c'est quand même une date
importante parce que c'est parce qu'il
ya eu ce vol qui permettait de venir
directement à montréal qu'on a vu une
augmentation importante du nombre de
personnes qui venaient au canada qui
n'en visite qui voulaient venir vivre au
canada on parle de 100 personnes par
jour à un moment donné à partir de 1979
le vol se faisaient toujours soit mis à
me soigner à ça a compliqué les choses
alors voilà ce qui se passe ça c'est
donc il ya 30 40 ans 41 à mon jeu ça
passe vite le temps et puis matthew a
pas 40 ans avait pas voilà j'avais je
pense une à huy sur notre site web
je vais vous faire honneur on a toute
une suite d'articles pour ceux qui
veulent en apprendre plus sur la
situation à haïti signé par le collègue
matthew il ya vraiment des marteaux qui
a signé la plupart d'entre eux on va
ferrer ont affiché ça ça s'appelle la
vidéo numéro semi ruraux
voilà voilà voilà voilà alors haïti un
autre journaliste abattu c'est de vous
cette semaine
ouais recommandation d'éviter de se
rendre en haïti si le canada recommande
d'éviter de se rendre et si on veut les
canadiens savent donc on a fait deux
sorties etc à ce sujet-là festival haïti
en folie
c'est elle 13e cette année vous avez
signé un article intéressant avec cet
homme là walter innocent valter
innocents étaient est un auteur est un
penseur et hirson site web très très
très très fascinant qu'est ce qu'il dit
oh je pense donc j'écris c'est bien déjà
qui crie ça passait ou sans réfléchir et
ça mais ce qui est intéressant aussi
c'est kim elle doit excuser moi dit il
met le doigt sur un problème de
représentativité de la de notre société
à l'image télévisuelle notre télé et
très monochrome très blanc alors que bon
notre société multiculturelle asiatiques
les haïtiennes et africaines et bien sûr
autochtone mais on la voit pas c'est
vrai qu'il a raison vous vous promenez
dans la rue je passe sur les rues dans
la rue dans dans la sphère attention su
depuis
alors on se promène dans la rue puis on
voit que montréal c'est ça vient de
partout
oui et puis on voit pas nécessairement
ça à la télévision ou dans les
télévisions dans les télévisions ou à la
télévision des mondiaux c'est
intéressant de mettre en avant aussi que
l'article qui recommande aux canadiens
de ne pas se rendre en haïti a été un
des plus populaires dans la section
française c'est fou du coup ça m'a
vraiment que les gens s'intéressent à
cette situation et qu'on qu'on fait bien
de reporter dessus de continuer à
reporter dessus parce que c'est c'est
comme on l'a vu c'est très grave et on
s'attend dans les premières prochaines
semaines à voir comment la situation
comme le disait monsieur voltaire je
sais pas qui a parlé de ça c'était à la
fin septembre c'est à lire ses yeux on
ne l'a pas riche passé on a fait un
article là dessus je sais que si bbc en
a parlé radio-canada a parlé je vous
montrais l'image c'est notre image qui
est que l'on tire dans notre
attendez voir que je trouve numéro huit
vidéos numéro vite c'est juste une
petite vidéo avec l'image c'est niaiseux
bg face à une vidéo avec une image voilà
et puis ça ouais ça me bois et bassons
je sais pas si on a fait un papier là
dessus moi je sais je n'ai pas fait mais
c'est ce député qui tirent en l'air
parce qu'il dit ma vie était en danger
il était au parlement armée et ça
représente bien la situation
l'image est très puissante en elle même
fin septembre un sénateur un sénateur
il a deux séries qui l'a blessé je pense
qu'un journaliste étranger du coup alors
se battre mais en tout cas c'est pour ça
que ça la nouvelle a probablement fait
le tour du monde on abuse et moi
j'aurais dit que c'est l'image du mois
de septembre mais j'exagère toujours
vous le savez alors mais là je vais vous
proposer dans quelques instants l'image
de la semaine et c'est pas pour tout de
suite je réserve le gâteau pour la
cerise alors moi j'ai bien compris on y
va avec la troisième question père
combien de boules pour ce jeu c'est 5
arte et puis vraiment lui il a conservé
toute ses boules mathieu online en vain
selig a perdu non mais moi j'en ai cours
du baril en a perdu 20 mais j'ai encore
une chance je peux dire a juste perdu 30
parce que le deuxième jeu on en perd 30
notre premier jour on a perdu tous les
deux ah oui vous auriez pas de me dire
ça ok très bien
troisième jeu léonie bassin kangoo la
perdre
complétez correctement cette tirade
célèbre de donald trump
je pourrais me tenir au milieu et tirer
sur quelqu'un sans perdre des lecteurs
je pourrais me tenir au mieux de quoi
est-ce que c'est à broadway avenue où
est ce que ces bébés phoques avenue est
ce que c'est c'est madison avenue
ou est ce que c'est des princes à venir
aujourd'hui faire soigner à vis des
fêtes avenue fabre à une des plus
grandes de new york
voilà c'est la plus grosse et la plus
connue à paris
bien sûr les guides de voyage c'est vous
ce compte là où il a une de ces tours
d'ailleurs et pas très loin un un bloc
de l'est sa venue
puis je pense qu'il a raison il pourrait
être quelqu'un puis arrêtez pas de
conséquences et on sait pas mais je
pense qu'il devrait pas testé la faire
mais moi si j'étais lui ni à un retrait
de tester la faire on regarde la bonne
réponse c'est fait la venue ou non
qu'elle savait tout vous vos bons livres
au boulot cette semaine fantastique
on y va pour la l'image de la semaine
allons-y sais c'est que c'était quoi
déjà le gâteau après la cerise on joue
très bien alors je peux je réponds
seulement par outardes on s animalier
travail que je vois bah on pourrait
parler d'une bête internationale ben ça
fait le 7 une nouvelle du canada qui
sert de l'offre fait le tour
international j'en suis sûr est ce que
c'est un rapport avec les élections
robin gros rapports des élections ce que
c'est un candidat en particulier fait un
candidat en particulier vous cacher là
est ce que ça valait sur les justin
trudeau nom maxime bernier non non plus
andrew scheer
adro scheer tiendront au gâchis vous
avez deviné bien quel contexte d'un
brushing à là c'est plus difficile
ce sujet des caisses quelque chose qui
leur ai dit cette semaine il a parlé
notamment de la possibilité lui aussi
d'un gouvernement minoritaire disant que
normal non si vous avez le plus grand
nombre depuis député si vous qui gagne
et qui vainquit diriger le pays pis
c'est vrai ça non non ce que c'est le
choix du de la gouverneure du gouverneur
général de fo le premier ministre
sortant a un avantage
la prépondérance proposé par exemple une
alliance ou coalition avec un autre
parti pour avoir un nombre supérieur de
passes de dicter ça c'est gros comme
c'est pas s'il ne comprend pas la
concession canadienne mais c'est très
gros comme affirmation est comme
réinventer la réalité c'est quelque
chose qui est dénoncé ces jours ci on va
regarder dans quel contexte il a fait ça
c'était ses déclarations concernant le
fait qu'ils n'avaient pas besoin de se
préoccuper du fait qu'il n'avait pas de
majorité pour former le prochain
gouvernement il n'y a pas de lien avec
ces faits avenue un nom qui n'est jamais
moi c'est moi je suis jamais bien la
cerise puis les pommes c'est tout à fait
différent alors sitv vous n'aurez donc
revenue avec sitv mercredi puis là il en
a il a rajouté du crémage sur le gâteau
c'était jeudi pour ceux qui
s'intéressent on a signé un article ce
matin je pense oui qui est déjà sur les
réseaux sociaux
c'est vrai sur si vous voulez aller voir
sur une autre page facebook
radio canada international vous vous
souvenez du titre seulement le mushir
doit être la dinde
écoutez c'est à voir donc ce récit
matthew officiellement vos
responsabilités j'en avais beaucoup de
wicked responsabilité une d'entre elles
c'est de nous aider ici à la préparation
de cette émission est aussi c'est d'être
sur les réseaux sociaux
et parce que vous êtes c'est un monde
que vous connaissez bien et puis aussi
il ya toute une refonte des balados
radio canada international organise
tranquillement est-ce quelque chose
qu'on peut annoncer des à saint-sever
chicaner par le patron et ce n'est pas
parce que faire attention et des coûts
tout le temps je sais pas exactement ce
qu'on peut annoncer je peux déjà
annoncer qu'on a lancé un nouveau projet
de facebook stories ou les nouvelles
facebook
du coup tous les jours vous pouvez
accéder à cela sa responsable en quatre
heures et c'est un visuel de deux des
trois interviews de journalistes en
français et en anglais
et du coup c'est très intéressant c'est
très interactif vous les avez
directement de votre page facebook en
vous aimez la page radio canada
international et vous avez juste à
balayer vers le haut et vous accédez à
l'article écoutez je vous dis de voir la
semaine prochaine alors se châtient
fabrice la description tâche de massy ou
la dernière phrase est très importante
c'est quoi ont besoin il accomplit
toutes autres tâches
[Rires]
joker 1
c'est une petite vidéo sur la semaine
prochaine de 2,3 édition de ça parce que
je pense que c'est super le fun de
retrouver ça sur le facebook de montrer
à quoi ça ressemble pour ceux qui
voudraient acheter le produit
c'est gratuit impasse vous pourriez vous
s'il voulait le consulter j'en ferai une
wii et on va aussi promouvoir les la
cyber lettre qui est très importante qui
sort tous les jours
ok et continue à promouvoir aussi cette
fameuse histoire de podcasts qui restent
oui un secret mais vous en saurez
bientôt davantage
razer prochaine 1 et c'est super le fun
on voir du plaisir à parler des ces
nouveautés qui se prépare dans les
coulisses et des fois qu'ils coulent
comme ça à l'antenne
voilà merci beaucoup matthew merci à toi
stéphane mathieu zazzo
et puis vraiment les marteaux merci à
lui bien mon cher et puis à la semaine
prochaine tout le monde
au revoir
[Musique]